florin bûches bois de chauffage posé
des rangées de cadavres encore une fois sur le credo et
puis ils ont tout aspergé d'essence et
mettre le feu à et apparemment c'est là que nous avons marché
s'est approché de la bière blonde et cette odeur ici
ce harry bien sûr il est comme ça tout le temps
nous aimons tellement tout le temps mon sentiment
ressenti aux yeux du niveau de tout
comprend qu'ils sont et sont libérés qu'il
dont elle n'était pas à ce moment-là
tout ce temps est fini pour eux
terminé
tu sais aujourd'hui c'est ton anniversaire
passé une telle soirée comme dans
maison parentale dans un cadre si chaleureux
ambiance conviviale un tel moment
qui est encore en quelque sorte
remplie de comportement de maîtresse, elle est tout
le temps nous a regardés et s'est tourné vers
l'utérus cire à l'utérus bosca aussi dur
votre comité régional
tasia nous regardant pensait déjà à
combien il est difficile pour nos mères de jouer aux échecs
leurs enfants sont ici dans ce
situation difficile
[la musique]
le matin je vois en quelque sorte la rose filante
puis immédiatement la pensée a été
que c'est une sorte de groupe d'atterrissage que j'ai regardé
la fenêtre
capitaine capitaine du service médical
Je suis son capitaine crochet dans ce qui se passait
quelque chose comme tirer
he oui tu es pressé déjà victoire signée
ce que ça fait avec des fleurs
Je serais certainement très heureux si
en effet quelqu'un a partagé
mes impressions sur ce que je
Raconté
[la musique]